مشاهدينا ستكون الوجبات السريعه التي
سنتناولها مستقبلا من صنع انامل الروبوتات
فهي ايضا من ستقوم بالرد عليك ايضا لتلقي
الطلبات كل شي روبوت حذر خبيره في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي من ان ملايين العمال في
مجال الوجبات السريعه سيفقدون وظائفهم في
فتره تتراوح ما بين 5 الى 10 سنوات وذلك
بعد ان تحل محلهم الروبوتات عشان الخبراء
الى الافضل من البشر اذ يستطيع استلام
اكثر من مليون طلبيه دون كلل او تعب
يعني عن جد قديش فعلا في وظائف في
المستقبل ستنقرض انا بالنسبه لي ما عندي
مشكله
حتى انا ما عندي مشكله انا على وجه تقع
ساتقاعد ايوه
باخذها من اصلها لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات